yes he conquers worlds and yes he's
hell-bent on universal domination
but that definitely isn't all there is
to darkseid from his origins to his best
comic book moments
everything you ever wanted to know about
darkseid
when jack kirby was concocting the idea
of dark side for his short-lived but
influential fourth world stories he
envisioned the ultimate evil in dark
side
he modeled the tyrant after adolf hitler
the real-life embodiment of evil and
tyranny
whose universal lust for power and
control is reflected in darkseid's
actually universal lust for power and
control
with apocalypse exemplifying a tyrant's
ultimate dream
a world of total control with no
resistance the one aspect of dark side
that wasn't modeled after hitler his
face that was somewhat modeled after the
actor jack palance
between 1960 and 1969 jack kirby and
stan lee co-created a number of the most
influential characters
in marvel history the x-men thor iron
man the silver
surfer the fantastic four and more kirby
left for dc comics in 1970 but he was
given a blank check to develop his own
mythology for the brand
he came up with a series of comics
centering around a series of new gods
of these gods the most frightening was a
menacing villain darkseid
a vastly powerful purple hued villain to
serve as a foil for dc's most powerful
superhero team
with kirby at dc jim starlin was put in
charge of growing marvel's array of
cosmic
titles he created a new cosmic villain
in the character of thanos
and overtly acknowledged his inspiration
from kirby's work on the new gods
but not darkseid stalin had copied
metron the new god knowledge seeker in
his mobius chair
until stalin's editor roy thomas
suggested he should rather copy darkseid
instead
thanos transformed from a thin new god
to a massive purple-faced tyrant that
worships death
and the rest is history in dc comics
history
there was a first world named god world
which existed 18 billion years ago
it evolved for 3 billion years into the
second world and the humanoid lifeforms
who lived there
began to attain godhood through a
gradual increase in power
this era saw vast advances in cultural
and scientific advancements and the old
gods became some of the most powerful
beings in existence
10 billion years later god world fell
into internal conflict between powerful
factions of gods
culminating in ragnarok the destruction
of god world
and the release of a massive wave of
energy throughout the universe
ceding worlds with the potential to
evolve gods of their own
in what became known as the third world
god world itself split into two
divergent planets
the good new genesis ruled by the wise
and powerful highfather
and the warlike dark and evil apocalypse
the fourth world emerged when these
beings attempted to attain
godhood around 30 000 years ago these
new gods and their two planets began to
wage war
of the two planets which the new gods
inhabit apocalypse and new genesis
the latter is an effective utopia while
the former is a massive
industrial city dedicated to
intergalactic war and dominance
in one origin story darkseid was born
axus son of the rulers of apocalypse
his older brother drax had attempted to
claim the omega force
itself a source of legendary power when
uxis killed dragston took it for himself
darkseid was transformed into the
craggy-faced monstrosity
he's best known as and took the throne
of apocalypse for himself
in the new 52 title relaunch darkseid
was retconned from new god royal lineage
to a lower class resident of the world
of the old gods he manipulated them into
turning on each other
and proceeded to absorb their powers as
they fell in this iteration darkseid and
the high father are brothers
forming the origins of apocalypse and
new genesis respectively
just as darkseid wasn't always a ruler
he also wasn't always the pure evil
hard-hearted god of evil we know
following his absorption of the omega
power and renaming himself darkseid
he fell in love with a scientist and
sorceress named suli
they married in secret against the
wishes of his mother queen heger
suli began to gradually tempt darkseid
toward goodness
and away from his plans of universal
domination and together the two had a
son
named calibach darkseid's mother hegre
fearing suley's positive influence over
her
son had sully poisoned darkseid became
even more hateful in his heart
and his mother forced him to marry a
woman named tiger
who gave birth to darkseid's second son
orion he sought his revenge
ordering dasar to poison hegera in
retaliation for her killing his love
and to stake his claim as ruler of
apocalypse
in the long-standing war between
apocalypse and new genesis
the two worlds achieved a temporary
peace with a novel deal
the rulers would exchange sons each
raising the other's progeny
darkseid gave up his second son orion to
be raised by the new genesis ruler
while the latter sent his son scott free
to live in apocalypse where he was
trained and tortured by darkseid's
minion
granny goodness for his part scot-free
found he had a godlike ability to escape
effectively all traps he eventually used
this ability to escape to earth with his
wife big bada becoming the hero mr
miracle
orion on the other hand became aligned
with the side of good as the greatest
protector of new genesis
and the one prophesized to defeat
darkseid still
at least one of his sons followed in
darkseid's footsteps darkseid's first
son callie back is evil
often serving as darkseid's second in
command though comic's law has made it
clear that darkseid respects his heroic
son orion
more than the sun following in his
footsteps as a new guard
dark side has a number of powers that
make him among the most formidable of dc
villains
his skills and powers include
immortality impossibly strong and
durable physiology
and rival tactical prowess and a command
over the omega effect
a form of energy that allows him to emit
omega beams
powerful energy beams that can lock onto
and never miss a target they can shift
direction in mid-air destroy planets
move faster than speedsters
and even harm the likes of superman and
that doesn't even include his omega
sanction
where an individual gets trapped in a
parade of increasingly dreadful
and hopeless artificial lives altogether
these powers make darkseid be under
formidable foe
his most devastating capability however
comes from his lifelong pursuit of the
anti-life equation
a mathematical equation that grants him
total control over all sentient life
through proving the futility
and hopelessness of life and freedom for
years he has searched the galaxies for
the legendary anti-life equation
a formula that would give him complete
control anyone who hears it is subject
to darkseid's absolute control
and it can even grant reality distorting
powers it's a long equation but its
mastery granted darkseid the ability to
attack earth
enslave billions and attempt to
reconstruct the planet as a new
apocalypse in final crisis
here's the anti-life equation in its
full glory
loneliness plus alienation plus fear
plus despair
plus self-worth divided by mockery
divided by condemnation
divided by misunderstanding times guilt
times
shame times failure times judgment n
equals y
where y equals hope and n equals folly
love equals lies life equals death
self equals dark side of course what
exactly the anti-life equation is
changes
depending on the story in jim stalin's
cosmic odyssey
the anti-life equation is said to be
part of a nearly all-powerful anti-life
being
one pushed out of this reality by dr
fate but which is beyond even dark
side's control
in grant morrison's seven soldiers
series a sort of reimagining of dc's
earlier team the seven soldiers of
victory
darkseid has discovered the anti-life
equation that allows him to control over
the free will
of all sentient life darkseid's actions
destroy the entire fourth world of new
gods
both apocalypse and new genesis and the
new gods retreat to earth by possessing
human bodies
in seven soldiers mr miracle issue two
we meet boss darkseid
a version of dark side in human form who
runs the dark side club
we discover that after his death at
orion's hand the immortal new guard
falls backwards through time
and becomes mortal attached to a human
form his plan here is to use the
anti-life equation to command fanatical
followers
alongside a super team of young villains
called the terror titans
one complication his human host is
rapidly decaying
due to the human form being unable to
contain his powerful
new god essence we see him take over
another human host
metropolis detective dan turpin before
attempting to conquer earth once and for
all
during final crisis darkseid's love of
waging war against gods has taken him
across the universe
but one thing many folks don't know is
that he once waged war and demigods as
an infant of darkseid's many children's
he has four sons and one daughter
grail grahal was born from the union of
darkseid and an amazonian assassin
mirena upon one of his visits to earth
she fled with the young grail to raise
her in secret
hoping one day the girl could grow
powerful enough to kill darkseid
during the dark side war the arc that
transitioned the dc universe from the
new 52 to rebirth
darkseid dies an adult grey or
resurrects the new god
using an ancient amazonian ritual
depositing his soul in the body of an
infant
the new infant dark side wants only one
thing for sustenance
souls grail proceeds to hunt down the
children of the olympian ruler zeus so
their demigod essences can feed
and empower the younger tyrant even as
an infant dark side is a willful
murderous controlling megalomaniac and
one hell bent on absorbing the power of
other gods
while many of his worst plots are
against fellow gods he's a major
antagonist to the justice league
especially the man of steel himself
superman is one of the few mortal
entities who has withstood his omega
beams
and his exemplary ability to inspire
hope flies in the face of the
hopelessness
that darkseid literally tries to create
in his foes
at the same time darkseid has
reluctantly partnered with superman on
multiple occasions
each time the two were faced with an
enemy that endangered both
why should we help you because my enemy
is your enemy in 1998's cosmic odyssey
darkseid has to join a slew of heroes
including superman
in order to stop escaped aspects of the
anti-life entity
at the heart of the anti-life equation
of course darkseid has plans of his own
but he still works alongside superman
for a time in our worlds at war
the dc universe and its heroes are
threatened by imperialx
the embodiment of entropy who has
continually destroyed the universe to
remake it in a perpetual cycle
darkseid ends up partnering with a host
of heroes including superman
wonder woman and the martian manhunter
to stave off the assault of the cosmic
menace
darkseid's machinations for defeating
earth and its heroes have always
involved a variety of elements including
treachery
the collective might of his minions his
own formidable powers
or the anti-life equation over the
tactician
darkseid has sometimes resorted to more
unique efforts
to undermine his enemies including
interfering in earth's politics to sow
chaos for a potential takeover
in the six issue series legends darkseid
uses glorious godfrey's powers of mind
control
and persuasion to turn humanity against
the heroes of the justice league
his motivation is his own
dissatisfaction with the legendary
status of earth's heroes
who continued to inspire humanity and
impede his ability to conquer
in the dark knight returns the golden
child darkseid teams up with the joker
to effectively re-elect donald trump the
latter is not directly named
but his image is used in parts of the
comic while trump-like phrases are
scattered throughout
darkseid enlists the joker as an agent
of chaos to get trump elected
antagonizing the populace and serving so
much division among the people that they
become pillars for his domination goals
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite comic book heroes and
villains are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one